how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some major news about Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
scott derrickson the director of the
first Doctor Strange film and the person
said to direct the second one has
dropped out and is no longer directing
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness so as it sits right now Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness has
no director scott derrickson took to
instagram not too long ago today and
said Marvel and I have mutually agreed
to part ways on Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness due to creative
differences I am thankful for our
collaboration and will remain on as EP
and EP for those of you who may not know
is executive producer now obviously this
is insanely big news but what does this
mean well he had creative differences
with Marvel Studios and you have to keep
in mind what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is everything interconnects and
what happens in one movie affects
another movie so when Marvel does a
movie they have to think long term how
will this affect our future movies and
the future of the MCU that can kind of
cut in to making a movie making it what
you want it to be so this could have
interfered but let's talk about the fact
that Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of madness was supposed to be the Imps
use first horror film now scott
derrickson at San Diego comic-con called
it a horror film he said it's the first
MCU horror film but Kevin Feige not too
long ago said that he wouldn't call it a
horror film and said he said that it
would include some horror aspects to it
but overall it wouldn't be a scary movie
now scott derrickson has expressed in
the past that he wants nightmare to be
the main villain of Doctor Strange - but
could this have changed well we weren't
really too sure about who the main
villain was going to be in multiverse of
madness at this point but with scott
derrickson gone there are probably going
to be some major changes made to the
movie he had a lot of influence
obviously over how the film was going to
go and what direction it was going to
take and unfortunately it seems like
Marvel Studios didn't really agree with
that direction now as far as Marvel
commenting on the situation they didn't
really have much to say but they did
speak with Variety the studio said
Marvel Studios and Scott Derrickson have
amicably parted ways on Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness due to
creative differences
we remain grateful to Scott
for his contributions to the MCU so
although we don't really know what the
creative differences were it's probably
the fact that scott derrickson wanted to
make this a horror film scott derrickson
has directed many horror films including
The Exorcism of Emily Rose and sinister
and it's pretty clear by what Kevin
Feige said before Marvel Studios doesn't
want Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness to be a horror film they don't
want a scary MCU movie at least not too
scary now fortunately for us the reports
do say that Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness as date is not
going to change the release date is
going to stay the same and this makes
sense because they haven't even started
filming yet and we're just now hearing
rumors and leaks about actors they're
trying to bring on board so they have
time to regroup and get their vision
together and that's the report right now
if I hear anything else about this news
I'll be sure to report it as soon as I
find out but let me know what you think
about this let me know why you think
they parted ways and would you have
liked to have seen a horror film in the
MCU be sure to let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on everything relating to the
MCU don't forget to follow me on Twitter
and Instagram and as always thank you
all so much for watching will fluff